first of all i was you seem like such a
practical person to me thank you and uh
and and no you really do you know highly
practical and then i heard that you went
to an astrologist recently and i thought
that doesn't seem like you
it doesn't it was a gift um for my 42nd
birthday my um makeup artist because you
know they're into astrology um he gave
me a gift to have my you know
astrological chart read and so i was in
a hotel with my sisters and cousins on
my birthday in san francisco and i got
it read and the woman and that's a joke
i said do you see me having any children
like we all know i'm not having children
and it was a man and he's like
no
and my sisters are like oh shut up and
then and he goes no i mean you're 41 and
i said actually i'm 42 today and he goes
oh you know okay 42 today and then he
said wait wait today
and i said yeah aren't you doing my
chart yeah
like is it the only single thing we're
supposed to be focusing on is you
reading my
birthday yeah
and then he's like oh yeah sorry you
know i get so wrapped up in this and i
was like oh shut up yeah i mean i mean
it's such a load of [ __ ] you know well
what kind of stuff did you want to ask
him did you want to ask him like you
know about your your relationships that
might be on the horizon i said am i
going to be ever get married and he was
like it was a long pause and then he's
like i wish i could tell you
yes
well he said at the end he goes i wish i
could tell you you're going to meet
somebody but you're not what he said
you're not going to beat somebody for a
couple of years you're kidding no no
it's fine i mean i expect that to happen
who's going to date me so i'm just
curious like uh you uh right now you're
just seeing guys i'm not really seeing
anybody i have nothing happening right
now but i'm i'm busy it's not like i'm
not you know i'm busy raising my two
dogs
that takes a lot of work busy raising my
two rescue dogs
exactly all right so you're not
interested in a long-term thing right
now uh no i mean i sure of course but
what are you looking for what kind of
guy do you like you once told me you
don't love redheads
you did you said that to me you're being
really honest you they you don't find
anything here sexy
that's true okay
your hair by the way has a lot of height
today
[Applause]
yeah
sometimes people come out and it just
goes